Jake:啊好好
Jake: Ah, okay okay.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay okay.
Jake:呃行但我现在在国内啊
Jake: Uh, sure, but I'm in China right now.
Jake:我国内我我过来大概要半个月吧
Jake: It'll take me about half a month to get there.
Jake:呃对对是
Jake: Uh, yeah yeah, that's right.
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah.
Jake:听不懂听不懂
Jake: I don't understand, I don't understand.
Jake:你说英文吧要不
Jake: Can you speak English, maybe?
Tasha: 你说英文吧
Tasha: Can you speak English?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 搞什么
Tasha: What's going on?
Jake:哈
Jake:我逗他玩呢
Jake: I'm messing with him.
Jake:我靠真的
Jake: Oh my, really.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Jake:新加坡移民局
Jake: Singapore Immigration.
Shure: 你让他说英文他撂了
Shure: When you asked him to speak English, he hung up.
Jake:对他掉了
Jake: Yeah, he hung up.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Ah, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 油条
Katrina: Youtiao (fried dough stick).
Jake:他就会说个哈喽哈哈哈
Jake: He could only say "hello", haha.
Tasha: 你放心
Tasha: Don't worry.
Tasha: 今天晚上我一定会把它吃掉的
Tasha: I'll definitely finish it tonight.
Shure: 你
Shure: You.
Katrina: 这怎么分啊
Katrina: How do we split this?
Katrina: 这个粥这么大拿碗
Katrina: This porridge is so big, get a bowl.
其他人：放心明天早上8点一定会叫你
Others: Don't worry, we'll wake you up at 8 AM tomorrow.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Jake:哈哈哈昨日重现啊这是
Jake: Hahaha, it's a replay of yesterday.
Tasha: 明天早上
Tasha: Tomorrow morning.
Shure: 昨日重现
Shure: A replay of yesterday.
Shure: 你不在这重现他吗
Shure: Aren't you going to replay it?
Katrina: 一定可以的
Katrina: Definitely.
Katrina: 我也定了闹钟
Katrina: I've set the alarm too.
Jake:看看你的快递
Jake: Check your delivery.
Tasha: 这是石头剪刀布哎呀
Tasha: This is rock-paper-scissors, oh my.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Katrina: 没醒
Katrina: Didn't wake up
Katrina: 按了定了4个闹钟全按了
Katrina: Set four alarms and still didn't wake up
Tasha: 垃圾转移
Tasha: Garbage transfer
Katrina: 看一下这
Katrina: Look at this
Shure: 来客之前不得收拾收拾吗
Shure: Shouldn't you tidy up before guests arrive?
其他人：就给我们的顾客看看这个
Others: Just show this to our customers
Katrina: 想吃什么
Katrina: What do you want to eat?
Tasha: 想吃怎么自己拿
Tasha: If you want to eat, get it yourself
Jake:盛情招待
Jake: Warm hospitality
Jake:哈哈哈随便吃
Jake: Hahaha, eat whatever you like
其他人：随便选随便吃
Others: Pick and eat whatever you like
Jake:哈哈随便吃
Jake: Hahaha, eat whatever you like
Jake:自己烤
Jake: Cook it yourself
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:还剩两个包子
Jake: Only two buns left
Alice:有早饭吗
Alice: Is there breakfast?
Katrina: 那
Katrina: There
Katrina: 好久没吃油条了
Katrina: Haven't had fried dough sticks in a long time
其他人： 你来吗
Others: Are you coming?
Alice:都啥呀
Alice: What's there?
Shure: 还有桌上一瓶伏特加帮我拿来
Shure: There's still a bottle of vodka on the table, bring it to me
Tasha: 音响呢不是说拿音响来吗
Tasha: Where's the speaker? Didn't you say you'd bring the speaker?
Tasha: 小
Tasha: Little
Shure: 哎有油条哎
Shure: Hey, there are fried dough sticks
Shure: 哦还是热乎的
Shure: Oh, they're still warm
其他人：看看以太坊掉下来没有
Others: Check if Ethereum has dropped
其他人：好购入我们的EGO 币了是吗
Others: Okay, you're buying our EGO coins, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
Jake:准备发售了
Jake: Getting ready to sell
Jake:我们少了很多充电宝
Jake: We're missing a lot of power banks
Jake:不知道发生了什么
Jake: No idea what happened
Tasha: 我还想说我少了很多皮筋呢
Tasha: I was just about to say I'm missing a lot of hair ties
Tasha: 我带过来至少10根不下皮筋
Tasha: I brought at least 10 hair ties
Jake:这充电宝咋还没送呢
Jake: Why haven't the power banks been delivered yet?
Tasha: 今天一今天只剩最后一根了
Tasha: Today, I only have one left
Alice:给了我一根
Alice: You gave me one
Jake:就没了呵呵呵
Jake: And that's it, hahaha
Tasha: 我是想扎个双马尾都扎不了
Tasha: I wanted to tie pigtails but can't
Jake:骗哦多少钱
Jake: How much money did we lose?
其他人：0.181l了
Others: 0.181 liters
Jake:哦这么少
Jake: Oh, that's so little.
Katrina: 这
Katrina: This...
Jake:牛批
Jake: Awesome.
Jake:炒币呢
Jake: Trading coins?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
其他人：这是拿命玩
Others: This is risking your life.
Jake:波动这么大
Jake: Such high volatility.
Katrina: 怎么
Katrina: How...
其他人：就还好昨天晚上蹲到一个点
Others: It's good that I waited for a moment last night.
其他人：蹲到0.18 然后及时
Others: Waited until it hit 0.18 and then quickly...
Katrina: 我一直想知道挖币的原理是什么
Katrina: I've always wanted to know how mining coins works.
其他人：就是一直算
Others: You just keep calculating.
其他人：拿计算机算法写
Others: Using computer algorithms.
其他人：然后你算到了前面多少位
Others: Then you calculate up to a certain number of digits.
其他人：是他指定的保险
Others: It’s the designated insurance.
其他人：你就OK了
Others: Then you're good.
Jake:你就碰上了
Jake: You hit the target.
Jake:然后这就是你的了
Jake: Then it's yours.
其他人：然后他就给你一点点币
Others: Then you get a bit of the coin.
Katrina: 啊那些程序算那东西啊
Katrina: Ah, those programs calculate that stuff?
其他人：这不是算
Others: It's not calculating.
其他人：这是发行的币
Others: It's the coin being issued.
Shure: 哎我是不是要给你拿我租的服务器
Shure: Hey, should I use my rented server?
Shure: 开始挖矿
Shure: To start mining?
Jake:哈哈可以
Jake: Haha, sure.
Shure: 反正闲着也是闲着
Shure: It's just sitting there doing nothing anyway.
Jake:他会办掉你吗
Jake: Will they come after you?
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Jake:试试试试
Jake: Give it a try.
Jake:反正你不用
Jake: You don't use it anyway.
Shure: 但是你在监控
Shure: But you're monitoring it.
Jake:他肯定在监
Jake: He's definitely monitoring.
其他人：币的价格就是共存在你的
Others: The price of the coin is just what's shared with you.
Katrina: 啊就是看你挖到那别人有没有挖到
Katrina: Ah, it's about whether you mined it and others didn't.
Katrina: 就同同个时间多少人
Katrina: Like how many people at the same time...
其他人：这个币的价值在于你觉得这个币未来
Others: The value of the coin lies in how you think it will do in the future.
其他人：嗯你觉得大家都觉得这个比未来好
Others: Hmm, if everyone thinks it'll do well in the future.
其他人：那他不就更实际吗
Others: Then it becomes more practical.
其他人：比如说我们ego币
Others: For example, our ego coin.
其他人：一开始一分不值
Others: At first, it's worth nothing.
Tasha: 啊肚子痛
Tasha: Ah, my stomach hurts.
Tasha: 真的没有办法工作了
Tasha: I really can't work anymore.
Tasha: 偷偷摸鱼吧
Tasha: I'll slack off a bit.
Tasha: 剪刀在外面吗
Tasha: Are the scissors outside?
Katrina: 在楼上好像楼上那个桌子
Katrina: They're upstairs, I think on that table.
Lucia: 我可以先把它摘下来安一下吗
Lucia: Can I take it down and install it first?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake:走拿快递去
Jake: Let's go pick up the package.
Lucia: 又可以去拿快递了
Lucia: We can pick up the package again.
Jake:呃因为他
Jake: Uh, because he...
Jake:有很
Jake: Has a lot...
Jake:你看你看他的快递你看他的快递
Jake: Look, look at his package, look at his package.
Tasha: 昨天没有人替我拿
Tasha: No one picked up mine yesterday.
Lucia: 昨天我的也没拿
Lucia: No one picked up mine either yesterday.
Lucia: 所以我就专门去拿了一套
Lucia: So I went and got a set myself.
Lucia: 对我当时应该把这边的一块拿上
Lucia: I should have picked up the one here too.
Lucia: 我以为他们给你拿了呢
Lucia: I thought they got it for you.
Lucia: 就是那个民宿的
Lucia: It was supposed to be the B&B's.
Tasha: 谁给我拿了
Tasha: Who got it for me?
Lucia: 民宿的
Lucia: The B&B.
Lucia: 本来民宿的
Lucia: It was supposed to be the B&B.
Lucia: supposed to拿我们所有人的快递
Lucia: They were supposed to pick up all our packages.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 你昨天应该说一声
Lucia: You should have said something yesterday.
Lucia: 我要知道你没拿我们就
Lucia: If I knew you didn't pick it up, we would have...
Tasha: 我给他打电话了
Tasha: I called him.
Lucia: 领导这是你的你的问题了
Lucia: Boss, this is your issue.
Lucia: 领导你反思哈哈哈
Lucia: Boss, you need to reflect, hahaha.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Hmm, yes.
Jake:我反思反思
Jake: I will reflect.
Lucia: 我那这么说来他们昨天就没拿几个
Lucia: So, they barely picked up any yesterday.
Lucia: 咱俩那一串都没拿
Lucia: None of ours were picked up.
Lucia: 就那个民宿
Lucia: Just the B&B.
Jake:你昨天发的那一串他啥也没拿是吧
Jake: The set you sent yesterday, they didn't pick up anything, right?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 我也
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 我觉得民宿
Lucia: I think the B&B...
Lucia: 他们这个工作态度要提升一下呀
Lucia: They need to improve their work attitude.
Jake:有问题
Jake: There's a problem.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:下一次去三亚就不找他们了
Jake: Next time we go to Sanya, let's not contact them.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 我们真的要去三亚吗
Lucia: Are we really going to Sanya?
Lucia: 还没有去过
Lucia: I've never been there.
Jake:你没有去过
Jake: You've never been?
Lucia: 没去过
Lucia: Never been.
Jake:没去过走
Jake: Never been? Let's go.
Lucia: 所以您要是在三亚做实验的话
Lucia: So if you do an experiment in Sanya,
Lucia: 你看我这个工作态度和效率怎么样
Lucia: How do you think my work attitude and efficiency are?
Jake:哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, it's good, it's good.
Lucia: 哈哈哈老板你考虑一下
Lucia: Hahaha, boss, consider it.
Shure: 什么什么时候去三亚呀老板
Shure: When are we going to Sanya, boss?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:什么时候去
Jake: When are we going?
Jake:五一之后去走
Jake: Let's go after May 1st.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:真的吗
Jake: Really?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Shure: 你等我答完辩的好吗
Shure: Can you wait until I finish my defense?
Tasha: 不等
Tasha: No waiting.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 我正好正好公费度蜜月去了怎么样
Shure: I can have a fully funded honeymoon, how about that?
Tasha: 公费度蜜月你还要把你女朋友带上
Tasha: A fully funded honeymoon, you want to bring your girlfriend too?
Shure: 我们干活效率都很高
Shure: We all work very efficiently.
Tasha: 哦是你啊
Tasha: Oh, it's you.
Tasha: 想看看是哪位男生
Tasha: I was wondering which guy it was.
Alice:啊累死我了
Alice: Ah, I'm exhausted.
Tasha: 你女朋友在北京吗
Tasha: Is your girlfriend in Beijing?
Shure: 啊是的
Shure: Ah, yes.
Tasha: 哦是他的
Tasha: Oh, it's his.
Tasha: 在西安
Tasha: In Xi'an.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: What?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 我说是他的在西安
Tasha: I said it's his girlfriend in Xi'an.
Katrina: 我是
Katrina: It's me.
Tasha: 他女朋友啊
Tasha: His girlfriend, huh?
Lucia: 想认识一下美女小姐姐
Lucia: I want to meet that pretty girl.
Tasha: 呵呵怎么回事
Tasha: Haha, what's going on?
Lucia: 哈哈哈因为我在西安我知道
Lucia: Hahaha, because I'm in Xi'an, I know.
Tasha: 我知道我说他怎么不说话哎
Tasha: I know, I was wondering why he wasn't talking.
Shure: 哎那你会说陕西话吗
Shure: Hey, can you speak Shaanxi dialect?
Lucia: 我会但我说的可能不那么标准
Lucia: I can, but I might not speak it very well.
Lucia: 不过北方话反正本来就是变的调
Lucia: But northern dialects generally have different tones anyway.
其他人：听听陕西话感觉挺好听
Others: Listening to the Shaanxi dialect sounds nice.
Lucia: 怎么要我说一段吗哈哈
Lucia: So you want me to say something in it? Haha.
Jake:来来一段
Jake: Yes, give us a sample.
Shure: 绿辣子6馍
Shure: Green pepper bun.
Lucia: 哈你这说啥我咋听不懂啊哈哈
Lucia: What are you saying? I don't understand. Haha.
Shure: 绿绿辣子
Shure: Green, green pepper.
Shure: 绿辣子6馍
Shure: Green pepper bun.
Shure: 什么那个
Shure: What's that?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 我我我因为我们家一般不说山西话
Lucia: Because in my family, we generally don't speak Shanxi dialect.
Tasha: 我在外面啊
Tasha: I'm outside.
Lucia: 就是只有只有我姥姥姥爷那一辈人
Lucia: Only my grandparents' generation speaks it.
Lucia: 他们才说山西话
Lucia: They are the only ones who speak Shanxi dialect.
Tasha: 输了怪不得怪不得烦死了
Tasha: Lost, no wonder, no wonder, so annoying.
Tasha: 刮不到输了刮不到
Tasha: Can't scratch, lost, can't scratch.
Jake:走走快递
Jake: Go, go get the package.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
其他人：雨轩
Others: Yuxuan.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
其他人：打火机还有吗
Others: Do you have a lighter?
Katrina: 打火机在楼上
Katrina: The lighter is upstairs.
其他人：在你房间啊
Others: In your room?
Katrina: 在那桌上
Katrina: On the table there.
Katrina: 大厅的桌上
Katrina: On the table in the hall.
Jake:雨轩还有快递吗
Jake: Yuxuan, any more packages?
Katrina: 我的快递还没到
Katrina: My package hasn't arrived yet.
Jake:好你英文名
Jake: Okay, your English name.
Jake:你有英文名吗
Jake: Do you have an English name?
Katrina: 我英文名可以现场起
Katrina: I can make one up on the spot.
Katrina: 可以可以有
Katrina: Sure, sure, I can have one.
Jake:嗯你哈哈哈
Jake: Hmm, you, hahaha.
Katrina: 我给你是吧发给你
Katrina: I'll give it to you, right? I'll send it to you.
Jake:那你你你自己
Jake: Then you, you, yourself.
Jake:现场起还是
Jake: Should we start now or...
Katrina: 啊今天要
Katrina: Ah, do we need to...
Katrina: 因为要用到吗还是怎么
Katrina: Because we need to use it or...
Jake:对要用一下
Jake: Yeah, we need to use it.
Katrina: 啊等一会去
Katrina: Ah, we'll go later.
Jake:这么现场戏
Jake: This is such an impromptu scene.
Jake:那就那就叫
Jake: Then just call...
Jake:那就叫勾吧
Jake: Just call it "Gou".
Jake:要不哈哈哈哈
Jake: Or, haha...
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 太难听了
Katrina: That's too unpleasant.
Jake:j
Jake: J...
Katrina: 他要叫我勾
Katrina: He wants to call me "Gou".
其他人：为什么
Others: Why?
Jake:英文名要给个英文名
Jake: You need an English name.
其他人： 你有英文名啊你
Others: You have an English name, right?
Jake:你怎么没有英文名呢
Jake: How come you don't have an English name?
Jake:想一想先起一个
Jake: Think about it, come up with one.
Jake:先起一个j
Jake: Just start with "J".
其他人：Jesus
Others: Jesus.
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
Jake:好可以
Jake: Okay, that's fine.
Jake:这有点牛逼
Jake: That's kind of badass.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 下
Katrina: Next...
Jake:古希腊
Jake: Ancient Greece.
Jake:古希腊古希腊
Jake: Ancient Greece, Ancient Greece.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：古希腊掌管闹钟的神
Others: The god of alarm clocks in Ancient Greece.
Katrina: 不是不是不是不是
Katrina: No, no, no.
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's good.
Jake:好古希腊
Jake: Alright, Ancient Greece.
Jake:走走拿快递
Jake: Let's go get the delivery.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:他太慢了
Jake: He's too slow.
Jake:走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Jake:够应该不够
Jake: Is it enough? Maybe not.
Jake:要不这样
Jake: How about this...
Jake:勾你来监工一下吧
Jake: Gou, you supervise for a bit.
Jake:怎么样古希腊
Jake: How's it going, Ancient Greece?
Jake:你来建功一下吧
Jake: Can you make some contributions?
Katrina: 可以可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure, sure.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Tasha: 好监工
Tasha: Alright, supervisor.
Jake:他们得得在进度上啊
Jake: They need to stay on schedule.
Jake:现在还挺乱的
Jake: It's still pretty chaotic right now.
其他人：等我几分钟嗯
Others: Wait for me a few minutes.
其他人：再等一下走
Others: Just wait a bit, let's go.
其他人：我有个快递三分钟就送到了
Others: I have a package arriving in three minutes.
Jake:你有电吗
Jake: Do you have power?
Tasha: 那再慢慢走就就就到了吧
Tasha: Then just walk slowly, and you'll get there.
Jake:你插个电吗
Jake: Did you plug it in?
其他人：我的快递哦
Others: My package, oh.
Tasha: 找不到包了
Tasha: I can't find the bag.
Tasha: 走吧呃肯定可以来得及的
Tasha: Let's go, we can definitely make it.
其他人：等我一下
Others: Wait for me a moment.
Tasha: 一个小时肯定
Tasha: We definitely have an hour.
Jake:好好好我拿一个拿一个拿一个
Jake: Okay, okay, okay, I'll grab one, I'll grab one.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:再见库西了
Jake: Goodbye, Kousie.
Jake:走没找着
Jake: Let's go, couldn't find it.
Jake:但是你可以用我的剑
Jake: But you can use my sword.
其他人：等等我等等我
Others: Wait for me, wait for me.
Jake:你要修硕给你取
Jake: Do you want Shure to get it for you?
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What is it?
Jake:你要你要先吃是吧
Jake: Do you want to eat first, right?
Tasha: 你要先吃就更等不了你了
Tasha: If you eat first, we can't wait for you.
Jake:啊好
Jake: Ah, okay.
Jake:是这样吗
Jake: Is that so?
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:31号
Jake: Number 31.
Jake:31号 对啊
Jake: Number 31, yeah.
Tasha: 那个人又在哪
Tasha: Where is that person again?
Tasha: 你去取过吗
Tasha: Did you go get it?
Jake:我取过
Jake: I went to get it.
Tasha: 你知道在哪吗
Tasha: Do you know where it is?
Jake:我知道的
Jake: I know.
Tasha: 你记住路了
Tasha: Did you remember the way?
Jake:我记住了
Jake: I remembered.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:可能吧
Jake: Maybe
Tasha: 精品床头
Tasha: Premium bedside
Tasha: 然后怎么走
Tasha: Then how to go
Jake:忘了可能是
Jake: Forgot, maybe
Tasha: 你最好没骗我
Tasha: You better not be lying to me
Jake:放心有执法记录仪
Jake: Relax, there's a body camera
Jake:你怎么买
Jake: How did you buy
Jake:你买了这么多东西
Jake: You bought so many things
Tasha: 那我肯定要把500块钱花完呀哈哈哈
Tasha: I had to spend all 500 bucks, haha
Tasha: 而且我的性价比很高的
Tasha: Plus, my value for money is really high
Jake:那确实
Jake: That's true
Tasha: 我都没有买名牌
Tasha: I didn't even buy any brand names
Tasha: 有个人买了一只兔子就买
Tasha: Someone bought a rabbit for 300 bucks, haha
Tasha: 了 300块钱哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake:谢斌竹应该搭着这个车来
Jake: Xie Binzhu should be coming with this car
Tasha: 我们问他能不能坐上他的车走
Tasha: Let's ask if we can ride with him
Tasha: 载我一程
Tasha: Give me a lift
Tasha: 为你一块
Tasha: For you, too
Jake:他得咱俩人的话
Jake: If he takes both of us
Tasha: 你下来我来骑
Tasha: You get off, I'll ride
Jake:对他下来咱俩上去
Jake: Yeah, he gets off, and we get on
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake:哈哈他和谢斌竹一起吃药
Jake: Haha, he and Xie Binzhu are taking medicine together
Tasha: 谢斌竹吃什么药
Tasha: What medicine is Xie Binzhu taking?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know
Jake:他说他有点小感冒
Jake: He said he has a little cold
Tasha: 小感冒我带感冒药了呀
Tasha: For a little cold, I brought cold medicine
Jake:他带感冒药了
Jake: He brought cold medicine
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow
Jake:他带感冒药了
Jake: He brought cold medicine
Tasha: 我带了感冒药
Tasha: I brought cold medicine
Tasha: 胃药发炎药消炎药
Tasha: Stomach medicine, inflammation medicine
Tasha: 什么药都带了
Tasha: I brought all kinds of medicine
Jake:今日破防
Jake: Today's breakdown
Tasha: 没有人问我呀操
Tasha: No one asked me, damn
Tasha: 我胃药也带了操
Tasha: I brought stomach medicine too, damn
Tasha: 我甚至掉了健胃消食片
Tasha: I even dropped my digestive tablets.
其他人：操
Others: Damn.
Tasha: 我怕我们吃太多了
Tasha: I'm afraid we ate too much.
其他人：操
Others: Damn.
Tasha: 哈哈操
Tasha: Haha, damn.
Jake:见到你之后谢斌竹每天得喝8个
Jake: Since meeting you, Xie Binzhu has to drink 8 cups a day.
Tasha: 我以为你在吃饭啊
Tasha: I thought you were eating.
Tasha: 我想着吃饭就不等你了
Tasha: I thought we'd eat and not wait for you.
Jake:买都买
Jake: Just buy it.
其他人： 你带的可能没有我少试的对吧
Others: What you brought might not be as effective as mine, right?
Tasha: 嘘
Tasha: Shhh.
Jake:哈哈哈回去我买的头孢
Jake: Haha, I bought some cefalexin when I got back.
其他人：我买的头孢
Others: I bought cefalexin.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 哦哦哦我带的是儿童充气颗粒
Tasha: Oh oh oh, I brought some children's effervescent granules.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
其他人：我买的对了
Others: I bought the right one.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Whoa.
其他人： 姐你说我今天彩票能中奖吗
Others: Sis, do you think I'll win the lottery today?
Tasha: 这会路过一家彩票店
Tasha: There's a lottery shop nearby.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 不知道我彩票最高就中过100块钱
Tasha: I don't know, the most I've ever won is 100 yuan.
其他人：现在让我干什么我就干什么
Others: I'll do whatever you want me to do now.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 那我们去刮张彩票吧
Tasha: Then let's go scratch a lottery ticket.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：姐让我刮我一定的刮
Others: Sis, if you let me scratch, I'll definitely scratch.
Jake:拿ego币和你换
Jake: I'll trade you for some ego coins.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:一个一个币14,000
Jake: Each coin is 14,000.
Jake:啊哈啊
Jake: Ahaha.
其他人：这是我们的未来期待
Others: This is our future hope.
Tasha: 彩票店对他说
Tasha: The lottery shop said to him.
Tasha: 那我把电给你吧行吗
Tasha: Then can I give you the electricity bill?
其他人：那要不起还得交房租太麻烦了
Others: If you can't pay, you'll have to pay the rent, it's too much trouble.
Tasha: 刮一张大7选尾号10的
Tasha: Scratch a big 7, ending with 10.
Tasha: 嗯十
Tasha: Hmm, ten.
Tasha: 十一二十
Tasha: Eleven, twenty.
其他人：啊 7
Others: Ah, 7
其他人：你讲那个啊
Others: You're talking about that, right?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 刮那张大七
Tasha: Scratch that big 7.
其他人：它是福彩不是体彩
Others: It's Welfare Lottery, not Sports Lottery.
Jake:什么什么大7
Jake: What big 7?
Tasha: 福彩
Tasha: Welfare Lottery.
Jake:大7是什么
Jake: What's the big 7?
其他人：就是c罗那个7
Others: It's Ronaldo's 7.
Jake:哦体彩
Jake: Oh, Sports Lottery.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:你也爱刮
Jake: Do you also like scratching?
Tasha: 嗯不爱刮
Tasha: No, I don't like scratching.
Jake:但
Jake: But...
其他人：你是不好久没回国你知不知道彩票店是最火爆的
Others: Haven't you been back to the country for a while? Lottery shops are the busiest.
Jake:是我不知道为什么
Jake: Yeah, I don't know why.
其他人：彩票店要排队
Others: You have to queue at lottery shops.
Jake:这大家这么闲
Jake: Is everyone so free?
其他人：就是就是
Others: Exactly, exactly.
其他人：这么没地方捐钱而已
Others: Just have no other place to donate money.
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Damn.
Jake:开始薅彩票羊毛了
Jake: Starting to milk the lottery.
Tasha: 薅彩票的羊毛
Tasha: Milking the lottery.
Tasha: 是不是嗯
Tasha: Isn't it?
其他人：我怎么感觉现在哪里彩票店都火呢
Others: Why do I feel like lottery shops are thriving everywhere now?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: They are.
Tasha: 我还了解了一下开彩票证的资质
Tasha: I even looked into the qualifications for opening a lottery shop.
其他人：我还真认识一个朋友大学毕业
Others: I actually know a friend who graduated from college.
Jake:开彩票店赚多
Jake: Do lottery shops make a lot?
其他人：那个人在那个哪里呀
Others: That person, where was it...
Tasha: 把体彩和福彩同时干下来
Tasha: Managed both Sports Lottery and Welfare Lottery at the same time.
其他人：他一毕业就开了一个彩票店
Others: He opened a lottery shop right after graduation.
其他人： 但我感觉彩票店一般赚的钱都是
Others: But I feel like lottery shops usually earn their money from...
Tasha: 一般都是打打票赚的钱多
Tasha: Usually make more money from selling tickets.
Tasha: 刮刮乐赚的少
Tasha: Scratch cards earn less.
其他人： 那天去咖啡馆接借火机
Others: The other day, I went to a café to borrow a lighter.
Jake:嗯你家那个狗狗是
Jake: Yeah, your dog is...
其他人：那个阿姨
Others: That auntie.
其他人：那个那个什么吧
Others: That, that what...
Jake:吧嗯
Jake: Um, yeah
其他人：嗯就是有个员工
Others: Yeah, there's an employee
其他人：不是那个店主那个员工
Others: Not the owner, but the employee
其他人：他说有打火机
Others: He said he has a lighter
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
其他人：他说直接给我
Others: He said just give it to me
其他人：我就觉得很不好意思
Others: I felt really embarrassed
其他人：我就直接看他递烟
Others: I just watched him hand me a cigarette
其他人：他非要给我递烟
Others: He insisted on giving me a cigarette
其他人：哦我不想要他的烟
Others: Oh, I didn't want his cigarette
其他人：他的烟太便宜了非要给我递烟
Others: His cigarettes are so cheap, but he insisted on giving me one
其他人：我绷不住了
Others: I couldn't hold it in anymore
其他人：我只能抽哇
Others: I had to smoke it
Jake:不给你打火机
Jake: Didn't give you the lighter
Jake:给了吗给了
Jake: Did he give it? He did
其他人：给了
Others: He did
Tasha: turn left all right
Tasha: Turn left, all right
Jake:都行都行都可以
Jake: Anything works, anything is fine
Tasha: 都可以
Tasha: Anything is fine
Jake:真的都可以
Jake: Really, anything is fine
Tasha: 全部都是自建房
Tasha: All of these are self-built houses
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
Tasha: 10年前我们家那也这样
Tasha: 10 years ago, it was like this at our place too
Tasha: 自建
Tasha: Self-built
Tasha: 怎么北京还能自建
Tasha: How can there still be self-built houses in Beijing?
Jake:卧槽这车有点牛逼
Jake: Wow, this car is pretty cool
Jake:就哈利波特
Jake: It's like Harry Potter
Jake:哈利波特自建房
Jake: Harry Potter self-built house
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Tasha: 什么魔芋
Tasha: What kind of konjac?
Tasha: 魔魔魔芋爽魔术
Tasha: Mo-mo-magic konjac magic
Jake:魔术麦吉克薇拉
Jake: Magic, magic, Tasha
Tasha: 麦吉克
Tasha: Magic
Jake:魔术哦
Jake: Magic, oh
Jake:魔术还没建完
Jake: The magic house isn't finished yet
Jake:还没建建一半
Jake: It's only half-built
Tasha: 哇哦
Tasha: Wow
Jake:在左边右边一起建
Jake: They're building on the left and right together
Jake:这么牛逼
Jake: So cool
其他人：他左边应该建好
Others: The left side should be finished
Tasha: 他这两根打通的你看
Tasha: Look, he connected these two.
其他人：左边建好了
Others: The left side is finished.
Jake:可能不打通呵呵
Jake: Maybe it's not connected, haha.
Tasha: 不打通
Tasha: Not connected.
Tasha: 哇这个
Tasha: Wow, this...
Jake:白宫
Jake: White House.
Tasha: 青藤客栈
Tasha: Ivy Inn.
Jake:White House
Jake: White House.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 请勿践踏
Tasha: Please do not step on.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 晒干
Tasha: Dry it in the sun.
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmph.
其他人：选个币让我炒
Others: Pick a coin for me to trade.
Jake:我一个ego币
Jake: I'll pick an ego coin.
Tasha: 我不行我不认识
Tasha: I can't, I don't know them.
Jake:炒ego币
Jake: Trade ego coin.
其他人：炒egob怎么样
Others: How about trading egob?
其他人：现在想盯多少钱
Others: How much do you want to set it at now?
其他人：你盯多少钱
Others: How much do you want to set it at?
Tasha: 可是花500块钱
Tasha: But spend 500 yuan.
其他人：就从我这花500块钱买下来
Others: Just spend 500 yuan to buy from me.
Tasha: 哎呦
Tasha: Oh my.
Tasha: 这是要经过你同意了吗老板
Tasha: Do you need the boss's approval for this?
Jake:我的钱
Jake: My money.
Tasha: 他说他是从他那买币
Tasha: He said he's buying coins from him.
其他人：对啊在中央银行就是
Others: Yeah, it's just like the central bank.
Tasha: 我靠那你不止一夜
Tasha: Wow, then you're not just...
Tasha: 一夜暴富了啊
Tasha: You're getting rich overnight.
Tasha: 好吧根本就没有人找你买是吧
Tasha: Alright, so nobody actually buys from you, right?
其他人：他妈现在给每个人发币
Others: He's giving coins to everyone now.
Tasha: 发的都是他妈的我的钱啊
Tasha: All the coins he's giving out are my money!
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：这是我的抵押的
Others: It's my collateral.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Tasha: 那这个一个币
Tasha: So this one coin,
Tasha: 你你们预估的是多少钱呢就是
Tasha: How much do you estimate it's worth?
Tasha: 就是你们给他定价是吗
Tasha: So you guys set the price, right?
Tasha: 然后自己要把钱充进去是吗
Tasha: And then you have to put your own money in, right?
其他人：其实
Others: Actually...
其他人：理解为我们花了400块钱买了
Others: Think of it as spending 400 yuan to buy
Tasha: 150个币
Tasha: 150 coins
其他人：买了一堆空气
Others: a bunch of air
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
其他人：之后每交易一次空气也要花钱啊
Others: And every time you trade the air, you have to pay
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh
其他人：因为要交易费
Others: Because of the transaction fee